this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
what's up guys it's definitely not a
decoy michael
to talk clones gods and pinocchio
jerry's
the fifth season of rick and morty is
already off to a great start
offering the mind-bending hilarity we've
come to expect
from our favorite geriatric genius okay
let's go that's his magic ocean horn
but episode two more duplicity really
intrigued us he's morty is it there god
damn it just tell me if i'm real sporty
do it
and not just because it involved
watching every main character meet their
earthly demise a few dozen times
rather we think the clue to
understanding the episode actually lies
in the opening
lines christian god is real he's been
asleep for thousands of years we're
gonna sneak up there and kill him
specifically because killing god might
be the one task
too ambitious for the smartest man in
the multiverse we'll explain in this
wisecrack quick take on rick and morty
why rick can't kill god and as always
spoilers ahead but before we get into it
i want to give a shout out to this
week's sponsor
surfsharkvpn surfsharkvpn helps you
secure your data with
industry leading measures by using
uncrackable encryption and the most
secure vpn protocols
this is especially helpful if you're
traveling because with surfshark
you can overcome location-based prices
on plane tickets and car rentals by
connecting to vpn servers in different
countries and because of surfshark's
encryption
you'll also be safe whenever you're on
public wi-fi there is also
surf shark search which works as an
extra ad block to allow for a peaceful
browsing session
one subscription will allow you to
protect all your devices and there are
apps for
all your favorites like pc mac android
chrome firefox
amazon fire stick and even your xbox and
playstation
surfshark is fast easy to use and jam
packed with features if you use the link
in the description and use the promo
code wisecrack
you can get surfsharkvpn for 83 off its
normal annual price plus
three extra months for free so go to
surfshark.deals
wisecrack or hit the link in the
description protect yourself online and
download surfsharkvpn today
and now back to the show now as we
mentioned
the episode opens with one version of
rick and morty eating a high protein
breakfast before their next mission
killing the christian god mob styles
whack his ass
of course things quickly go awry the
entire family is offed by some vengeful
squids who are apparently jealous of
rick's
anatomy well we're talking about me it
could be anything maybe jealous of my
penis size
i had sex with their queen my dick's too
big the episode then seemingly abandons
the killing god plotline
instead exploring the implications of
rick's totally normal choice to build an
entire race of familial decoys
but we'd argue that on a deeper level
the theme of wanting
and failing to kill god remains a
poignant through line
now to be clear nobody would ever accuse
rick sanchez of being a
religious dude his worldview is pretty
squarely centered around a central
belief in his own genius in this way
rick shares much with 18th century
enlightenment philosophers
who sought to relocate the place of
meaning and truth away from religion
that is
faith in some divine all-powerful being
and instead
center it around human thought and
creativity this was the catalyst for
that era shift from religious
faith to secular reason as the primary
source of human knowledge
in this way rick is just a more
ego-maniacal foul-mouthed
enlightenment-style thinker
like like kant if kant partied and it's
this shift from
faith to reason that one german
philosopher friedrich nietzsche
was talking about when he famously and a
bit melodramatically
wrote that god is dead and that we
killed him see
as humans increasingly stopped needing
religion to explain how the world works
or to set our moral compass pointing
north
we no longer needed god and could
instead chill out and revel in our
awesome humanity and that was the end of
human suffering right
well according to nietzsche's 19th
century live journal
not so much instead nietzsche called
this abandonment of god
nihilism and not in an edgy coen
brother's way julie doesn't care about
anything
he's a nihilist rather he thought that
when enlightenment philosophers sucked
god out of their intellectual paradigm
they also left nothing in god's place to
give value meaning or purpose to human
life
without the bearded guy upstairs to tell
us how to be good people he argued
life becomes as empty and meaningless as
a taco filled with air
which which i i guess that's just a
tortilla
and this nihilism thing really seems to
sum up rick's whole
vibe nothing really means anything so
why not fly around the multiverse
starting
with very little regard for either
cosmic consequences
or the hurt feelings of his immediate
family god is deader than dead
and nothing has replaced him except
rick's big
big brain but here's where we get to
what's most interesting about this
episode
rick the og anti-god guy goes on to
create decoys in his own image in a
very god-like way and those decoys then
go on to embrace of all
things religion we see this most
explicitly when puppet
beth riles up a crowd of decoys with her
low-key evangelical preacher act
convincing them to join the cause which
functionally seems to be a religion that
views rick
as a somewhat dickish god figure we are
decoys
brought into the world by an unloving
god here
beth's religious impulses become a
rallying cry that unites the decoys in a
common goal
at least until the flying squid decoys
wrecked and this all
raises a big question is rick secretly
driven by religious impulses too
to figure that out let's turn to french
psychoanalyst jacques lacan
who believed that eradicating god from
western thought wasn't just a one and
done thing
he argued that even if we consciously
relinquish our faith in god
or make our reddit username sexy atheist
69
there's still something going on in our
little brain parts that remains out of
our control
our unconscious and according to lacan
our unconscious belief in god
never fully goes away even after we find
out that our dental insurance plan
doesn't cover mouth guards
in lakan's theory of the symbolic humans
still need
some kind of big other to orient our
lives and values
especially when it comes to things like
philosophy and politics
and this kind of explains why rick is
driven to start playing god
replicating the act of creation by
making tons of decoys
sure he says he's doing this to protect
his family
after that trouble with space beth i
made passable copies of the family and
placed him around the country as a
buffer zone to protect
why does he always want to be hunted
jerry's not important right now dad but
he clearly gets a real kick out of
playing old testament god
but that's just it i'm not a man i'm god
oh you're just made in my image q indeed
the dynamic that manifests between rick
and his decoys is very much one of
creator and their
creator much like the dynamic between
the divine and humanity in the bible and
other monotheistic texts
like the grumpy god of the old testament
he has no qualms about destroying his
creations
that is to say killing his own children
though
i guess at least the old testament god
gave his children a chance to live by uh
by smearing dead animal blood on their
doors and in turn
just like god's sex-positive human
creations rick's decoys quickly go
ham on religion first playing god
themselves by creating more decoys
and then by forming nascent religious
structures why
one of them explains pretty succinctly i
i might not be the real rick but even if
i'm not
he made me or the me that made me which
means somewhere inside of him is a
version of rick capable of hearing that
a version of rick who's sorry i'm sorry
about the clone thing too
this suggests that they're propelled by
the same generative drive that compels
rick to start making decoys
in the first place what's more the
decoys seem to accept rick as their god
even as they resent him remember this
decoys
brought into the world by an unloving
god and driven
to destroy ourselves by the uncertainty
he creates here beth's rallying the
crowd into a sort of
religious fervor which fits lacan's
point that these religious structures
are
so ingrained in our psyches that they're
functionally inescapable
but lacan's idea that religion is
inescapable
shows up most literally in the show's
after credits coda
we learned that wooden puppet decoy
jerry is now immortal
traveling aimlessly through time much
like a god who can't die
even though he really really wants to
eventually his head is nailed to the top
of the cross during a public crucifixion
christianity again here poor sentient
puppet jerry finds out that in some
future society
christianity is going to get a fun
reboot this perfectly fits lacan's
theory
that this religion stuff sticks around
in our unconscious so
of course society will eventually
reproduce it a few moments earlier
though we get the real
punchline of the episode when what seems
to be original rick and co
had been flying above the earth in a
spaceship this whole damn
time oh [ __ ] looks like someone killed
the decoy family
get it like a transcendent god floating
around in the heavens lording over their
creations on earth
it's pretty cool so why can't rick kill
god because he is god or at least a
blue-haired version of some divine
creator no matter how much he's
consciously a nihilistic atheist he's
still motivated by an
unconscious drive towards religion
towards replicating biblical lore
and this is why for lacan no matter what
kind of mafia tactics rick and morty
employ
they'll never be able to murder god once
and for all because
god will always live on in our
collective unconscious
but what do you guys think is lecono
right that it's impossible for us to
escape some
unconscious desire to believe in a
divine being who creepily watches up
or did he just die too early to bro out
at the global atheist convention
let us know in the comments and
definitely check out our rick and morty
podcast the squanch
dear our thoughts on this episode and
the rest of the season big thanks to our
patrons for
all your support decimate that subscribe
button like you're a decoy killing
yourself
and don't forget to ring that bell and
as always thanks for watching
[Music]
later
[Music]
you